okay so if you are overweight vitamin D
supplementation will not help you at
least that's what this study that just
came out from Harvard says they looked
at people who were BMI 25 and over and
25 and under and BMI is not the perfect
measure but it's something and what they
found was that if your BMI was over 25
means you're overweight then be a
vitamin D supplementation has very
minimal effects for you but if your BMI
is under 25 then you're looking at a 30
to 40 percent reduction in cancer deaths
and other autoimmune related issues
interesting just another reason why if
uh you got a couple extra pounds that
hit you over New Year's and Christmas
this might be just another little push
to say hmm maybe 2023 is the year I'm
gonna get healthy